hi I'm Dan Marino and if anyone knows
the value of protection it's me I take
care of the hands that take care of me
with isotoners low-cut again for the top
I said cut what is this a rewrite Gianna
how about you super sir I'm here because
the SAT is racist oh you don't think so
who created the test rich white guys who
scores the highest on the test Asian
chicks wait a minute I know you
you're Kareem abdul-jabbar you play
basketball for the Los Angeles Lakers
I'm sorry son but you must have me
confused with someone else
my name is Roger Murdock I'm the
co-pilot well it's my opinion that the
root cause is a lack of self esteem Oh
Oprah talks about that all the time
Oprah don't know crap back when I was
growing up nobody had self-esteem and we
turned out fine you're a rock ow you
make me a better woman
look it's Mike Ditka you know Sammy Sosa
a super kid ie quitters for breakfast
and I spit out their bones delicious and
it's gonna be the hardest most difficult
thing you ever attempted it in your
entire life but you know what when it's
over get emotional when it's over when
it's over you guys are gonna be
champions my god you got a big champion
nice degree need some of this hey you
can't park that animal over there it's
illegal
when I was young one who was so
dangerous I joined the army and we
invaded the Persian Gulf before vacation
to make most sense so why are we here
we're because maybe I want to go to
college and maybe I don't I won't know
until I get in and find out how much
[ __ ] it really is okay I'll make you
a bet for real I bet you $100 that you
can't score 700 points on your SATs
Oslo Solaria must sleep